hi I'm David silver clay welcome to bug
i guy comm come on in and I'll give you
a tour so bug eye guy comm is really all
about this car and we were absolutely
passionate about these cars and so now
it's kind of spawned this whole sea of
bug eyes
this car is obviously called a bug eye
because of these headlights and it was a
very inexpensive seventeen hundred
dollar sports car it happened to be
great performing little cars they're
really fun to drive they're very nimble
the steering is really quick
they're never gonna win a drag race
because there are tiny little engines
but they're great fun to fling in the
turns and it's a really fun car to drive
another thing that's really cool about
bug eyes is that there's no door handle
at all the door latches inside so that's
how you open this car and what that does
it was again a cost-saving measure but
what's so cool about it from my
perspective is it makes for a really
clean line you don't have any you know
any handles sticking out or indentation
or anything in the back there's no trunk
lid so to get to the trunk you reach in
behind the deceits in 1979 I bought a
bug eye while I was in high school I
loved the thing and took it all apart
painted it with my brother-in-law in his
driveway and it's one of the few things
that I've kept for 30 plus years my
father and I would look in the Sunday
Times and circle ads that were of
interest and we'd go look at collectible
cars together in a way this business
grew out of that you know I mean it it's
my passion it's also my job